foreign
part one
chapter one
wake up
John brushed off the disembodied voice
and buried himself deeper into his dream
it was probably Carter or someone else
from dispatch coming to get him for
being 20 minutes late to his shift
the last person 20 minutes late to a
shift caused the breach of a class 5
info Hazard and the deaths of 12 brave
men and women all gold heart recipients
after this ceremony side command made
sure everyone knew that
perhaps it was Zaid Manville John's boss
pink slip in hand coming to give him his
first ding on an otherwise spotless
record another thought flashed briefly
in his mind perhaps it was one of ahab's
best or some other task force clad in
Black rifled trained on Jon's forehead
with orders to evacuate the block or if
the subject is unresponsive to kill on
sight
the memory of site 19's Infamous October
breach still left a burning hole in the
conscience of those working on site and
is the reason most sleep with pocket
knives or other sharp objects within
Arm's Reach of the bed
it might as well have been overseer one
itself standing above John
nothing could compare to what his Mind's
Eye was seeing deep in the recesses of
his soul
it was an angel
an angel to rule them all and it was
dead on the beach
the carcass was a fatted thing its
putrid scent seemed to permeate time and
space directly into Jon's nostrils
its mass was amorphous made of bubbling
postures of oil and blubber too big to
be anything of Earth's oceans the size
of a small house at least
it looked made of wax melted from some
unseen candle wick atop its disgusting
shape
underneath its folds John sensed form
structure
order
a skeleton of Titanic strength and
beauty how he knew this he could not say
it was only a dream after all
John looked down to inspect his hands
but found he was formless his vision
hovered five foot eleven off the Sandy
Beach despite his masslessness he felt
the nip of the Wind on his nose and ears
and the pressure of the sand on his feet
so he walked wearily at first but with
greater confidence as he neared the
carcass
it was awful yes and repugnant but it
was dead
and not a curiosity to be poked and
prodded like the stories he used to hear
of Fantastical beasts washed ashore in
some cold desolate Place found by
Farmers or tourists unexplainable by
modern science
they were all dolphins or manatees of
course half disintegrated by the salt
water or digested by the wildlife
distorted Beyond identification but
ultimately natural
safe
the thing on the beach however was
unmistakable to someone else it could
have been a great Oak charred by some
ancient fire or lightning strike it
could have been a woman with eyes of
Steel weeping for the dead and the
Terrors that yet live
but to John it was the carcass of a
beast he remembered from childhood a
beast that in a movie he could not
recall the name of had devoured a puppet
made of wood who he thought was a boy
the terrible Dogfish he thought it had
given him nightmares once as did all
things born of the sea visions of
churning festering water of slime and
slush and the soup of Life flashed
before his eyes beasts Beyond size and
time holding the Earth like a marble
between shark teeth and bullying
letting it sink to the bottom of the
universe to fester and rot in the brine
it had been years since he pondered
these thoughts and for the first time in
his adult life John felt the adrenaline
of deep existential Terror
he screamed reflexively raising his
non-existent hands to Shield his eyes
from the horror that the carcass implied
the beach which once seemed to expand
infinitely in every direction suddenly
felt a lot smaller on one side mountains
reached impassively to the sky blotting
out the stars on the other a sheer wall
of water rolling like a cloud at
impossible speed and in the middle
John
the carcass and the entire sum of all
things real and imagined past and future
barreling at the speed of light down
down all the way to the bottom where the
pressure is so great that everything
becomes one indistinguishable mass of
blubber and oil
John screamed and the carcass howled and
the wave crested and crashed rushed to
his feet and wake up
and John woke
chapter 2.
the bedside intercom buzzed the shrill
voice of Randall Carter Chief dispatcher
of the night shift John's hand shot out
from under the bed sheets like a rocket
missing the intercom's receiver by a
millimeter and sending the half-filled
glass of water beside it on the
nightstand spiraling to the floor
he cursed and sat up wiping the sleep
from the corners of his eyes his body
was coated in a Sheen of sweat and his
boxes clung to his skin Like Glue he
leaned over and flipped on the
intercom's receiver
yeah Carter I'm here he checked the time
409 am
he wasn't late and that was good he
didn't much like being late
something must have tripped the
perimeter senses
such occurrences happened more than he
liked to admit site 184 was a tight
operation but things slipped through the
cracks all the time you run a big enough
ship you're bound to get Barnacles on
the hull it was inevitable what's not
inevitable though is the speed at which
you scrape them off in the words of
Chief dispatchers Aid Manville boss of
the intercom every second the Barnacle
stays on the ship his 10 minutes you're
going to spend polishing the stain it
leaves on the steel
except Zaid had replaced Barnacle with
Insurgent spy
John pressed on the button again
stepping out of the bed and over the
shards of glass stretching halfway
across the cold floor perimeter Bridge
again
do you need me for this Connor's voice
responded no actually
John lost his balance and cut his heel
on the glass she [ __ ]
what what happened nothing Carter
nothing I'll be right there he hung up
he'd have to sweep up the glass later
Randall Carter was aloof when it came to
damn near everything
everything but surveillance
he had the eyes of an eagle and the
attention span of a collegial math
department which is why he managed
nearly every channel of video and
intercom fade between the hours of 12
and 6 in the morning every night for the
past
well as long as Jon had been on site
which was going on two years come next
spring
if something was so interesting that it
got Carter excited
that would be something to see
Jon threw on some clothes and walked out
the door
chapter 3.
as he walked the frigid corridors of
site-184's administration block John
couldn't stop thinking of the Visions he
had seen mere minutes ago
the last moments of the dream the Wall
of Death flooding forth until it was
mere inches from his face and the sense
that along that thin strip of land
between the sea the sky and the
mountains was something incomprehensible
to the human mind a presence so Grand
that it seemed to Encompass the universe
itself
and that if the universe was on that
beach with me
what is that [ __ ] where is that [ __ ]
he pushed the thought from his mind but
it clawed its way back in
it was only a dream he thought
that dream seemed to scream back
then why can't I stop thinking of it
s timing had been impeccable just last
week he had been informed of the
formation of the Department of citation
studies which he briefed to cite command
along with the rest of the morning's
announcements he had also heard through
various non-official channels of the
incident in France and the Mad ramblings
of the now anomalous Lee DuPont
lay DuPont
the name sounded familiar
someone from maintenance
dispatch interacted with nearly every
division of the site but the names were
easy to forget he'd know if he saw his
face
John was good with faces
the hallway terminated at a non-descript
black door its tinted viewport obscured
by criss-crossing wire reinforcements
the word dispatch was plastered at eye
level in neat white paint John gave
three short knocks before swiping his
card and letting himself in
the room was dingy stained permanently
by an ever-present cloud of cigarette
smoke two men sat hunched over the CCTV
feed to the left was Carter in his
favorite black leather chair dirty
blonde hair slicked back he was wearing
a red bomber jacket adorned with patches
honoring the various teams he had served
over the course of his work site 19
Nighthawks site 17 graveyard area 2
Prowlers MTF gamma 9 high in the sky and
half a dozen more at least
Carter hadn't been able to go one full
day in his life without bringing up some
patch of his in conversation but Jon
still didn't know the stories behind
half of them
one of his hands tabbed anxiously on the
table the other held out a cigarette
lighting it was Philip Morgan assistant
director of site security
though hunched over at the table Morgan
towered over Carter by several inches
his dark hair was also slicked back with
a Widow's Peak that made him look like a
greaser past his prime
he was wearing as he did most days The
Standard Security dress written across
his back was an obnoxious reminder that
he was indeed security if his physical
presence didn't give it away
Morgan himself a lifelong smoker had
tried on several occasions to quit for
good on account of his rapidly
deteriorating voice the doctor had shown
him an X-ray of his lungs which had
looked to him like the paper bags he
used to burn holes into way back in the
third grade
sometimes he used those same bags to
catch small Vermin around the yard
comma Morgan thought and so he quit the
Habit still he eyed the lighter he used
to set fire to Carter's cigarettes
seductively and thought of nothing but
the small vermin
Carter heard the door open awkwardly
spinning to face the shadow backlit from
the Pearly wine hallway
good you're here he waved John over come
take a look at this
John approached the cluttered deck
ignoring the cigarette butts and
half-crumpled cans of carbonated coffee
the workspace was almost professional
dispatch had about the budget of a small
preschool ma did it could still afford
enough tank to keep the ship running a
sixth of the Department's funds must
have been spent on the four 30-inch flat
screens arrayed on the wall each showing
12 or so scenes of the facility various
Labs alleys and parking lots some showed
anomalous Woodland and one screen camera
6b11 which had not been used for any
active security incident in the past
decade was flashing an obnoxious warning
action required perimeter breach
this particular camera showed a
semi-circle of sun a stretch of beach a
mile and a half to the west of site-184
illuminated by a pair of ghostly
floodlights Beyond The Arc of light was
the inky Blackness of sea only it should
have been blackness
on the horizon just beyond the gentle
crests of the choppy sea was a speck of
light bobbing up and down with the pots
of the waves
it's a goddamn boat John thought
which wouldn't have been very strange if
it wasn't for the fact that site-184 was
40 miles from the nearest population
Center and protected by several
redundant tripwire surveillance systems
that would have told them if something
as big as a small porpoise got within a
half mile of camera 6b11
whatever this boat is it's either sliced
through several state-of-the-art
submerged pressure sensors or its open
season for the white coats down at the
anomalous vehicle Labs you look like
[ __ ] rough night gotta asked over his
shoulder eyes still fixed on the
flickering white dot in the sea of black
yeah just a an image of the wave flashed
in his mind followed by the stench of
the carcass it's just a bad dream
what is it the two men at the table
continued to stare intently at the
screen Carter with burning curiosity and
a touch of fear and Morgan where the
haze one gets right before a bar fight
the two of them had a long enough
history of dealing with trespasses the
rest of the dispatch called it playing
fetch that they had begun to develop
trades within the craft once the suspect
could be identified it was usually a
lost tourist or thrill seeker never
really worth anyone's time but particles
protocol
the two would intervene Carter would be
soft-spoken the voice of reason a camper
or a park ranger once he pretended to be
an intern for a film studio coming to
Notifier wandering elderly couple that
they were stepping onto this set of a
nature documentary this setup worked in
most cases the security breach would
walk itself home and everyone was happy
no amnestics required
but one suspect a 20-something-year-old
conspiracy blogger and UFO Hunter didn't
feel like playing along with Carter's
sorry sir this year's restricted federal
land and I'm gonna need you to turn
around and head back up the street
please and I decided to pull a pocket
pistol he had bought from a friend the
week before
he managed to get one shot off grazing
the shoulder of a very surprised Carter
before being shot in the head by a very
thrilled Morgan an ever-growing part of
Morgan wished every fetch could end the
way it did that day
Carter tapped the screen it's some kind
of vessel I think looks like it could be
a fishing boat we don't have much until
in that region some kind of blind spot
for the sensors we'll have to bring it
up with command after we're through here
it was almost always civilian but it
felt good to ask
Carter shrunk probably we need to go
down there and check if it was something
else that would have done something
anything by now I've been watching it
for some time and it hasn't moved Morgan
spoke reminding everyone he was still
paying attention what if it's a
distraction you know a sting to get us
out there so they can get the jump on us
you'd like that wouldn't you John said
not so jokingly Morgan always wanted a
fight even when he couldn't always get
one well we're gonna take care of this
or what Morgan smiled his horrible grin
yeah we'll take care of this Bruce has
the speed already
get your gun
[Music]
chapter 4.
the ride out to Phantom light was quiet
save for the Mindless hum of the scpf
Rascal a 30-foot speed boat the kind
you'd find with the Coast Guard or maybe
the cartel
it had arranged long enough to check up
on little errands like these but too
short for anything substantiative big
enough to get the job done too small to
do it comfortably
the four men rode in cramped silent
three of them John Morgan and Carter sat
along the edge of the boat the fourth
was agent Bruce Mitchell who stood at
the helm in awkward silence as the boat
flopped and splattered over the waves
Bruce Mitchell was a fat man head Bolder
than an egg his face half obscured by a
comically large mustache Jon thought it
looked fake but who would ever fake a
mustache as Gordy as that Bruce was the
sole operator of the scpf Rascal he had
practically built the thing giving it as
much personality possible without
sullying its inconspicuousness around
the steering wheel and underneath the
dashboard were countless stickers
insignias of bands and national parks
graffitied inside of the boat like the
underbelly of a skateboard unlike Carter
Bruce never talked about any of them he
didn't talk much at all except when it
was someone telling him which way to
steer the boat or wet pocket still John
sensed strange intelligence underneath
Bruce's anti-social silence they might
have been friends in another lifetime
the client did give John some much
appreciated time to think he closed his
eyes trying to ignore the Curious stairs
of Carter and Morgan his mind wandered
in the dark reaching out for the ever
slipping memory of that Phantom dream he
thought of the sensations the sand the
spray he gritted his teeth the stench of
the carcass it was fading fast the
sensation of utter totality that had
crushed his soul into a fine dust just
hours before was now only a tinge of
pain
this should have provided him some
comfort but it only left him feeling
cold and Hollow like some part of him
was still on that beach Racing for the
impact of that cyclopian wave
I have to go back
I have to see the carcass
there is more there is so much more
the beach stretches on and on and on and
voices
John pulled his mind from its recesses
and came two back on the speedboat it
felt like something out of a dream
Carter was saying something to Morgan
we need to be careful about this we've
got no Intel no counter measures
backup's a good 20 minutes out if they
can't even get our calls from here relax
Carter it's probably one of the locals
drifted a bit too far from the good
fishing spots Morgan laughed as he
pulled his side on from its holster
he gave it a look before continuing but
if things go south
well have I ever failed you before
John spoke up have the boat on idle
Bruce I want a clean exit path for us in
case we need to bail don't want anyone
dying if it doesn't have to come to that
the ship was closer now the glow of its
single light flickered dimly over the
tips of the waves
as it neared John got a closer look the
thing looked cartoonish like a tugboat
from the 40s
pale frayed life breweries hung along
the ship's railing a single smokestack
huffed black plumes which blended
effortlessly into the night sky
its bow arched comically Towards the Sky
revealing a deep black hole
the ship couldn't have been longer than
50 or 60 feet but its presence felt
Monumental like looking up at the base
of a skyscraper across its whole word
Dusty brass portholes eats the color of
the night air
after a moment of confusion Jon found he
couldn't count them or rather he could
count them but his mind would glaze over
after he reached six or seven
it was as if the ship stretched on and
on past the Horizon to places unknown
John couldn't take it all in at once
despite how hard he concentrated it was
as if the space the ship occupied was
not supposed to be there
yet was the thought was terrifying so he
shut it down he let his eyes settle on
the sole Shining Light Atop The Deck it
looked to be a lamp of sorts moving with
the sway of the ship
pull around Bruce Will board from the
other side Morgan was standing one leg
propped up on the edge of the boat
he'd get a fight tonight one way or
another
Carter sensed it too but knew there was
no use stopping him besides there was
always the possibility that this wasn't
a lost fisherman and that this fetch
could quickly escalate and become a big
deal in which case he might be thanking
Morgan for his itchy trigger finger
Bruce let out a grunt of acknowledgment
and spun the speedboat's whale hard to
the left the boat drifted maintaining
its momentum as it wrapped around the
front of the dread ship the ACT
terrified John to his core and he
shielded his eyes with one hand
he'd been lucky
he hadn't seen an active Cognito Hazard
since the rudimentary ones they gave out
during basic training the simple glyphs
that made your ears sting or cause blood
to spill from your nose
now he knew
this is what it feels like
the others hadn't seemed to notice their
faces were alone yet scouting the ship
for signs of an ambush but they lacked
the Visage of dread that slowly crept up
Jon's face the boat was now parallel to
the ship Carter reached up its Hull
affixing one end of a climbing rope to
the ship's guardrails he hoisted himself
up then turned back to extend a hand to
Jon he took it and was lifted to the
ship's deck empty he thought
or maybe not
he flashed a look to Carter which seemed
to say I'll have a look around
Carter nodded and turned to help Morgan
the ship felt strangely artificial like
something out of a museum of industrial
era seacraft
none of this Equipment Works
it looked like it did and he indeed felt
the gentle hum of motorization beneath
his feet but he couldn't shake the
feeling that this was all an illusion
that any moment the curtain would be
pulled back and he would find himself
not on a ship but on the deck of some
unknowable esoteric machine
this place is death
the ship looked empty though John paced
around but found no signs of Life the
ship swayed gently with the waves every
so often it would dip too hard to the
left or right and a thin Vapor of Ocean
Spray would miss the deck
John could see now that it wasn't very
big but it still hurt his head to
concentrate on the ship's dimensions
in the center was something like a cabin
which connected to the Smoke Stack and
probably led to the engine somewhere
below deck John was reminded of an old
cartoon he'd seen as a boy where a
monochrome Mouse whistled gleefully in
an eerily similar cabin
he never did trust that Mouse
and he certainly didn't trust this cabin
next to the pale white bulkhead that led
into the cabin was a flickering oil lamp
the lamp looked ancient years of salt
water spray had turned its gold colored
metal to a rusty red
it dripped a line of black paste which
pulled on the deck underneath it in a
sickly iridescent puddle John felt a
tinge of recognition at this and thought
back to the oily fettered carcass on
that Beach
the flame inside cast Dancing Shadows
across the neck
etched into a small brass plate beside
the bulkhead was an inscription
the Sailor
and jolt shot down John's spine here he
did not know why
something about those words brought
forth some innate fear within him as if
he had relived some traumatic childhood
memory like an arachnophobe seeing a
tarantula on the back of one's hand
he knew what was beyond the door as
surely he knew his own name he knew he
must enter and confront whatever lay on
the other side
there was no way around it
it would spell death surely for others
but perhaps even for him
it was now cold and raining and his
breath came out in hot white puffs
this place is [ __ ] creepy what's up
there Morgan appeared on John's left gun
drawn
cabin I think
John could not say for certain what was
really behind that door
but it sure as hell wasn't a cabin
Carter held back sweeping his eyes back
and forth across the deck
Carter might have been smart enough to
know something was wrong here maybe he
felt this sting at the back of his head
whenever he tried to picture the ship in
its totality
but he was not a memeticist had no
training with glyphs of Madness or
knowledge of their functions
and so he was blind
I cannot save them from what's to come
move I'll handle this one Mogan pushed
past pressing his ear to the bulkhead's
cold metal
he waited a moment face contorted in
concentration listening for the clang of
footsteps and the sound of movement
only heard was a hushed rhythmic
rustling he couldn't quite place
behind him Carter gazed back and forth
back and forth every few passes noticing
new Rusty pipes broken dials frayed bits
of rope and cloth strewn across the
ship's deck
his eyes grew wide and he choked back a
scream
somewhere down at the surface of the
water Bruce leaned idly against the
wheel of the Rascal has a cold sweat
broke out on his bald head
the hair on his arms stood straight up
and for a brief moment the cool
intelligence John had thought he'd seen
in the man poked through his hazy eyes
and he felt fear the likes of which he'd
never known in his most harrowing of
nightmares
Morgan reached for the door's handle
John felt every urge to speak to stop
the ACT he knew would condemn them all
to death but his body was frozen tears
began Welling in his eyes and he felt
the crushing presence of Fate on his
shoulders
this is how things were meant to be as
it was decided Aeons ago and Aeons from
now
I'm sorry
he managed to croak under his breath a
momentary sign of confusion or perhaps
contemplation flashed across Morgan's
face as he pulled the handle
the door glided effortlessly its rusty
hinges making no sound as the bulkhead
cracked open
a fan of white lights shot out from
where the door split from the cabin
Morgan realizing everything all too late
used his weight to slam the bulkhead
shut but it swung out fast and hard
seeming now to act on its own accord it
knocked into the terrified Morgan
sending him reeling back with a hollow
thud
blinding light poured over the ship like
a supernova spilling out across the sea
and bleeding into the sky John let it
bathe over him for a brief moment his
mind was ripped from his body he saw
Beyond the Door what he knew was there
couldn't articulate
a green sea full of monsters
lapping expectantly against a long flat
Beach
chapter 5.
John awoke on the beach
he recognized instantly the scent of
salt in the air the Cool Breeze against
his cheek he looked down and saw his
body
am I dead the beach was as Bleak as he
remembered it being on his left was the
sea coated in a thick fog that prevented
Vision past a few hundred feet on his
right the black bases of mountains their
tips hidden from view up was only a sea
of gray but he knew above him was the
moon and stars and things beyond
comprehension
he knew what lay in front of him but
resisted looking as long as he could the
stench burnt his eyes and he didn't know
how long he could gaze upon the carcass
before it would begin to fray his sanity
but then
he had a voice
care to sit stranger
catch your breath John Spahn arms
reflexively taking a defensive stance a
few feet behind him said a man at a
campfire he looked like he just walked
off the set of Deadliest Catch dressed
head to toe in dirty yellow rubber a
fisherman's dress
his clothes were torn in places coated
in a permanent Sheen of water and grime
he was old but he looked much older The
Contours on his face told a long story
baked in sea salt
wiry white hair poked out from under his
floppy yellow bucket hat
he bit the end of a tune-up pipe long
since having burned off what little
tobacco at monts carried
he sat on a piece of splintered
Driftwood the only aberration on this
pristine Beach John could see
beside that carcass he reminded himself
the campfire was dying coughing up the
last bits of Ash as it burned through
the crumpled newspaper and pine needles
used for its fuel
the man had held the Stick Over The
Flame which skilled a piece of white
flesh from some foreign animal
[ __ ] he said or would you rather keep
looking at that thing he gestured to the
carcass
John cautiously lowered himself near the
fire
it seemed to Glow brighter in
recognition if only for a moment
the two sat in Silence with only the
pops of the fire to break the still air
the man held up a stick hungry
John said nothing
there had been too much excitement for
Hunger to be an issue but eventually his
biology would catch up to him
the man laughed
I don't blame you this stuff tastes like
poison
gets better with salt he reached into
his coat and pulled out a pinch of fine
white dust
he powdered the meat and ate it all in a
single bite
chewy too
he broke the empty stick over his knee
and threw it into the fire
after a moment
John spoke
what is this
he said it more like a statement of fact
than a question
part of him knew the answer already
this is the beach the beach you used to
dream of as a kid
remember
how there be monsters with fins like
knives and teeth that shred Steel
red sky at night Sailor's Delight
Red Sky at morning Sailors take warning
I think you know that already
the man said in a wispy voice a better
question would be who am I
search your mind
I'm not supposed to be here
indeed he wasn't of every Vision every
fleeting memory of this place since the
days of kickball on the field Jon had
stood on these Sands alone
the thought of another sitting here with
him should have terrified him to the
core but the man's presence was soothing
a reminder of his sanity
the man held up his hands
don't worry I'm just passing through
a traveler
I'm here because of that
he pointed to the caucus reminding John
of its stench oh I could smell it an
ocean away
couldn't help myself from taking a peek
I think that their carcass might be a
genuine angel
we don't see many of those anymore
usually it's just Apostles the real fun
ones die out at sea
too deep for harvesting this stretch of
beach might just be the jackpot boy
the man's words flowed over John he was
only half listening his attention was
fully on the bends and folds of the
carcass his mind was struggling and
failing to recreate what it must have
looked like in life
stop it or you lose your mind
John snapped back and turned to face the
man
is this all real
it can't be a
I thought it was all just a dream
does this look like a dream he laughed a
Wheezy chuckle
I'm afraid not
you're where we all go when we
when is this hell
or Heaven Maybe
I haven't decided
but I've seen this place before I I know
this place
I've always known
you even said yourself I know where I am
the man granted I'm not pulling at your
leg if that's what you're asking I saw
this place too before I woke up here in
my dreams
place is funny like that
and what is this place
the man gave an impatient look like
Jonah just asked what color this guy is
of course John knew this place was Earth
but not from my time
that was a limp answer though and he
knew it
there was more to it than that but he
didn't think this man had the answers
one question still burned in his mind
are you the Sailor the man looked up
confused how do you mean
well before I woke up here I I was on a
ship I saw a door it had the Sailor
written next to it the man shrunk
first I've heard of it
John sat back defeated
this was the first time he had relaxed
his body and he was beginning to realize
how exhausted he really was
could I really be dead
did the dead get sore
it was shocking how fast Jon's old life
was slipping from his memory
dispatch seemed like a lifetime away
hey why don't you get some rest you look
like you might fall over I'll see if I
can catch something in the meantime
tomorrow we'll Harvest that whale and
get out of here
don't want to stick around until
something else catches the scent of that
thing
John was too weak to protest he laid his
head back against the Driftwood and
gazed absently Into the Fire
the man spoke up you know I never caught
your name
mind's Irving
he extended a withered hand
John fought off sleep long enough to
reach out and meet it with his own
John Del Mar
and then he was out
chapter 6.
somewhere far away a ship the color of
the night to read its ugly head
Ed on the bodies of three men their eyes
wide and empty faces holding suspended
screams
the fourth was elsewhere having Survived
The Madness of the door
the Sailor was called from the void the
dreadship thought
it would have survived the journey
its metal creaked and rattled
it was old
aeon's old
it was tired
but there was more work to be done
and so it turned its face pointing
toward the location of the next its mind
in full anticipation for the day it
might return home
to the place of green Seas
monsters
[Music]
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Indy versus the world
big sip
Timothy
zargaron
the Morrigan
fire of prime
Spencer are doing
rubbish bin 69
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J telp
vinyl
zazapan
Lemke
Dr Briggs
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
oh crop guy
and James Saba if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgan
thank you
[Music]